Die Eintracht aus Braunschweig startete furios in die laufende Saison, um nun seit zwei Monaten sieglos zu sein. Woran liegt das? Der KSC hingegen mischt mal wieder ganz oben mit, obwohl sie ihm nicht ganz so viele zugetraut hatten. Was macht Christian Eichner also so gut? Wir wagen einen Blick auf die 2. Liga-Teams, die bislang weniger am Vorkuss standen, auch hier im Rasenfunk, mit Anna Lautenbach und Thomas Haufe. Let's go!
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Profis zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Gili Landkampf. Waakra, Martin Waakra.
Und das Anzündung. Markus Kurt aus dem Bivou.
Alex hat den Schuh!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, okay, ja, ich erkenne diesen Ausschnitt. Wie soll ich sagen? Also, es gab tatsächlich Chancen, die nicht genutzt wurden. Und es ist so, dass für diejenigen, die die Chronologie des Spiels nicht erkennen, wir haben jetzt die vierte Niederlage in Folge eingesteckt. Das heißt, davor war es schon so ein bisschen schlechte Stimmung. Ein bisschen, wie entwickelt sich das? Wir haben viele rote Karten bekommen, oder gelb-rote Karten, eine rote Karte bekommen. Wie entwickelt sich die Mannschaft? Finden wir wieder so in diese Stimmung der ersten Spiele, die ja wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr positiv gewesen ist. Und mit diesen ganzen Fragen und so einem Anflug von Druck gehst du in das Spiel gegen Paderborn. Und du bist die ersten 30 Sekunden nicht in Rückstand. Dann ärgerliche und ich finde relativ sinnbildliche Szene. Wir sind im Ballbesitz. Wir sind in der Vorwärtsbewegung kurz vor Mittelkreis. Wir verlieren den Ball gegen Paderborner Spieler. Das ist ja super früh im Spiel. Also der ist so kurz vor Sprint im Tempo, aber der geht nicht mehr voll aufs Ganze. Muss er ja gar nicht. Das hat ja noch alles zu tun. Und flankt dann lange rein. Der Innenverteidiger ist irgendwie noch nicht so richtig anwesend. Kopfballtor, 1-0 Rückstand. Das ist halt der Worst Case, wirklich ein schlimmer Start. Und dann rappeln wir uns so ein bisschen. Und das ist so, dass das, was wirklich nicht fehlt, ist irgendwie Engagement oder Kampfgeist oder so, dass ich denke, ich merke schon, die Mannschaft möchte. Ich würde aber ein Fragezeichen hinter dem mit der Struktur machen, was du gerade zitiert hast, weil die fehlt mir wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr doll. Das muss ich schon wirklich sagen. Also, wir haben jetzt einen Trainer, der viel über den Kopf kommt und viel übers Herz, wie auch immer, also viel über, er formuliert viel Werte, viel spricht viel von Mut, von Kampfgeist, von nicht hängen lassen, von, ne, auch von Männer sein natürlich und so dieses ganze, dieses Segment natürlich.
Am Ende steigt der männlichste auf das Wissen.
Am Ende steigt der männlichste auf, genau. Und ich habe im Moment ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die Bemühungen über Strukturen verloren gehen, über den Bemühungen zu zeigen, dass man engagiert ist. Und dass das aber eher in Hektik kippt. Und dass das eher in komplett absurde, lange Bälle, so von kurz hinter der Mittellinie, so Chip-Flanken in den Strafraum von Spielern, bei denen ich denke, du kannst das doch besser. Was ist denn deine Idee dahinter? Und deswegen muss ich sagen, habe ich mich über die Aussage vom Trainer geärgert. Weil ich es mag, wenn ein Trainer nach solchen Spielen auch öffentlich sagt, das war nicht gut. Weil ich das auch nicht schlimm finde. Ich finde nicht, dass der Trainer damit irgendwerem in den Rücken fällt oder sich angreifbar macht oder die Mannschaft nicht in Schutz nimmt oder so. Sondern eher im Gegenteil. Ich würde eher sagen, er nimmt Verantwortung auf sich und ja, genau, frag mich. Ja, genau, also was das soll, ich kann es dir nicht sagen.
Also ich war natürlich nicht sauer oder angefasst, weil auch da die emotionalen Vermittlungen nach Braunschweig sind gering. Aber ich war irritiert von diesen Aussagen, weil ich eben auch überhaupt nicht fand, dass das inhaltlich ein gutes Spiel war. Es war von den Werten her ein gutes Spiel, also die du betont hast. Braunschweig wollte, es gab auch eine Phase rund um das 1 zu 1, in der man gespürt hat, mit der Einwechslung von Lino Tempelmann, geben Dinge. Aber es ist halt auch lustig, vor einer Buckhouse hörte ich mir Benjamin Kessel an, den Geschäftsführer Sport, der sagte, er hat die Abläufe vermisst. Also damit auch sehr konterkariert, was sein Trainer dann sagen sollte. Und das leitet vielleicht ja diese Niederlage, die in meinen Augen letztendlich verdient war, weil Braunschweig insgesamt– ich finde, dass innerlich eben nicht bessere Team war. Es war sicherlich eng, aber Paderborn konnte von dieser frühen Führung profitieren und hat dann sein Ding gemacht und war die reifere, besser angelegte Mannschaft, wie ich finde. Auch wenn sie dann profitieren, dass am Ende Braunschweig so ein bisschen der Kopf verloren geht nach dem 1 zu 1. Aber Grund um erst mal eine Niederlage, die okay ist. Und die leitet ja dazu über, zu den Dingen, die du auch schon erwähnt hast. Ich für meinen Teil von außen erkenne eben keine Spielidee, denn Intensität allein ist keine Spielidee. Und es gab einen sehr interessanten, sehr ausführlichen Artikel vom NDR. Der NDR bringt da ja immer mal wieder für die Vereine der Region so Datenstücke, Artikel raus, die sehr datenbasiert sind. Und dort haben sie mit einem Datenanbieter zusammengearbeitet, der mal diesen Jagdfußball, den Heiner Backhaus spielen lassen möchte, unter die Lupe genommen hat und geguckt hat, naja, ist das denn Jagdfußball? Also besteht der Fußball, den man bislang sieht, wirklich aus intensivem Anlaufen und hohem Pressing, vertikal mit direktem Offensivspiel, hohe Intensität und Zweikampfstärke, Umschaltspiel, aber auch ja Momente für Dribblings. So, das kann man ja unter Jagdfußball erst mal so verstehen. Und ich will die Leute hier jetzt nicht langweilen. Fazit ist, man sieht quasi nichts davon, auch datenbedingt. Es liegt zum einen nicht daran, dass die Mannschaft nicht will. Man ist beispielsweise bei Sprints– ich muss nochmal gucken, ob es jetzt nach dem kompletten Spieltag immer noch so ist –,Aber zwischenzeitlich war man da auf Platz 2 in der Liga. Es kann nicht so viel schlechter geworden sein, seit den Sonntagsspielen. Intensive Läufe, Lauf, Distanz, da ist man mindestens mal in der oberen Tabellenhälfte. Also die Mannschaft läuft, kämpft und das war, glaube ich, auch das Faustfahren der ersten beiden Spiele, dass du dir einfach niedergerungen hast, die Mannschaften. Aber die Spielidee mit Ball ist in meinen Augen bislang nicht vorhanden. Und ich sehe keine Struktur, ich sehe lange Bälle und die Hoffnung, dass sie irgendjemand festmacht. Dabei hast du gar nicht unbedingt auch den Spieler, der die festmacht, sondern du hast Spieler, die du eigentlich flach tief schicken möchtest. Also ein Jadimsi beispielsweise oder ein Conté. Die willst du ja nicht hoch anspielen. Das ist ja Quatsch. Du willst sie ja tief schicken und da haben die ihre Stärken. Und das haben sie ja sogar in der Saison schon bewiesen. Es gab ja Spiele, wo du dachtest, oh krass, damit können die Gegner wehtun. Aber abseits dessen sehe ich persönlich sehr wenig. Es wird sehr viel in den Formationen gewechselt. Also keine Formationen, hat der Datenanbieter auch herausgekehrt, wurde länger als ein Viertel der Saison bislang gespielt. Bei acht Spielen nicht viel. Also keine Formation, hat zwei Spiele überlebt. Und das verunsichert diese Mannschaft zusätzlich, hat man das Gefühl. Und dadurch geht irgendwann ja auch eine gewisse Intensität im Spiel verloren. Also die Mannschaft fängt extrem intensiv an und lässt irgendwann in den Laufwerten und so weiter extrem nach. Und ich glaube nicht, dass das daran liegt, dass die Mannschaft aus der Puste ist, sondern meine tiefste Überzeugung– ich habe jetzt auch ein paar Fußballspieler im Leben geguckt– ist, kaum eine Mannschaft läuft wenig, weil sie faul ist. Sondern Mannschaften laufen viel, weil sie von der Idee überzeugt sind und nicht groß nachdenken müssen. Wenn sie ins Nachdenken kommen, bleiben sie stehen. Das sieht man bei Hertha auch immer wieder. Aber sobald sie laufen– und Hertha hat jetzt gegen Münster 127 Kilometer abgespielt, das sind 12 Kilometer mehr als bislang im Schnitt. Die sind quasi einspieler-mehr gelaufen. Oh Wunder, funktionieren Dinge. So, und bei Braunschweig, die fangen motiviert an, merken dann irgendwann, ja scheiße, unser Trainer hat wieder vergessen, uns die Werkzeuge in den Werkzeugkasten zu legen. Was machen wir denn jetzt eigentlich? Und hören auf zu laufen. Und das ist ein einigermaßen desolates Bild, wenn man das auf eine ganze Saison zieht. Weil mir– hilft mir da, Anna– fehlt so ein bisschen die Fantasie dafür, wie will denn Braunschweig ein Fußballspiel gewinnen?
Ja, ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Also die ersten– wir hatten ja das erste Spiel gegen Magdeburg, dass wir in Unterzahl sogar 1-0 gewinnen konnten.
Imponierender Auftritt.
Durch so ein Traumtor von dem Schalker Neuzugang. Aydin. Super Typ, wirklich. Also wirklich so ein Zehner-Typ, so wuselig, enger Wendekreis, gut am Ball, so viel Intuition. Und dann haben wir gegen Fürth gespielt. Das war halt, ne, erst das Heimspiel spät, das 3-2 gemacht, aufregendes Spiel hieß das und so. Und dann kam ja dieses monumentale Spiel gegen den VfB Stuttgart, dieses Pokalspiel unter der Woche. Wir hatten eine englische Woche, weil ja Stuttgart Pokalsieger geworden ist und durch den Supercup am Pokalsamstagabend spielen dann Meister und Pokalsieger unter der Woche. Natürlich gibt es legendäre Pokalabende in Braunschweig. Marc, du erinnerst dich an die, ich glaube, es war irgendwie 9 zu 9 oder so.
Nee, da klingelt gar nichts. Also immer souverän in Braunschweig weitergekommen.
Ja, ich fand es total toll, dieses Spiel. Und ich kenne keinen, dem das anders geht, gar nicht so sehr wegen, wir sind ja dann am Ende auch ausgeschieden, also wir hatten ja gar nichts davon. Aber wir waren im Mai in der Relagation im Free-TV und wir sind nicht so oft auf diesen großen Bühnen. Und dann siehst du irgendwie deinen Verein vor der Free-TV, vor dem Free-TV-Publikum wirklich einfach um seine Existenz kämpfen und gerade so noch den Arsch durch die Tür kriegen. Und ein paar Monate später ist es dann eins der besten, also eins der besten Pokal-Erstrundenspiele, die wahrscheinlich jemals gespielt worden sind. Zumindest, und er muss es wissen, hat Basti Schweinsteiger gesagt, als Kommentator hat er sowas wirklich rar gesehen live. Und das hat irgendwie, das hat uns alle irgendwie gut fühlen lassen. Und das beantwortet alles nicht deine Frage, weil ich sie auch gar nicht beantworten kann. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie wir jemals ein Spiel gewinnen sollen. Der Kader ist gar nicht so schlecht, aber er macht ja nichts aus dem, was er tun sollte, nämlich Fußball spielen. Und dann kam es nach der Englischen Woche zu einem Ligaspiel gegen Arminia Bielefeld. Und es lief eigentlich alles sogar ganz gut. Wir lagen eins, neun in Führung. Und Anfang der zweiten Halbzeit hat sich unser Innenverteidiger Frank-Hart verletzt, Neuzugang von Preußen Münster. Und ich fand es total cool, dass wir den gewinnen konnten. Innenverteidiger super, weil Armin Bitacic war gegangen, Säule in der Mannschaft fehlte, Innenverteidigung mit Zweitliga, Abstiegskamferfahrung top. So, der verletzt sich. Und wir haben vor seiner Verletzung in der Liga vier Gegentore rufgefangen. Und in der gleichen Anzahl der Spiele, nach seiner Verletzung zwölf. So. Also irgendwie stimmt da was nicht so richtig. In der Defensive natürlich auch gefördert durch gelb-rote Karten und eine rote Karte. Dazu muss ich sagen, die Statistik ist halt übel. Wir haben, glaube ich, wir haben drei gelb-rote Karten, eine rote Karte in sechs Liga-Spielen bekommen. Wir sind aber jetzt keine– da ist niemand kaputt gegangen beim Gegner. Das war schlechtes Timing. Das war Leichtsinnigkeit und es war halt– und das kreide ich halt einfach so dieser darüberstehenden Jagdfußball-Tirade an. Dieses, ich muss was machen. Ich muss was machen. Im Zweifel mache ich es falsch.
Also die überdrehen.
Genau. Und es ist ja total gut, dass du keine Angst davor hast, Fehler zu machen. Aber es ist schlecht, wenn du so sehr Aktionen haben möchtest, dass du im Zweifel einen Fehler machst, als dir Zeit zu lassen. Und ich sehe halt viel Voreile im Spiel. Ich sehe viel Hektik. Ich sehe viel Sprints, aber viel unproduktive Sprints. Ich sehe auch Sprints, die nicht synchron gehen mit der Gesamtlaufleistung, die meistens schlechter ist als beim Gegner. Also heiße Luft, so ein bisschen. Und mit all due respect passt auch dieser Begriff irgendwie ganz gut zum Trainer.
Perfekte Überleitung, denn für uns mal gerne ein… Man hat ja nun… Ich erinnere mich, welcher Spieler war das? War das Sven Köler? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Nach der Redigration hat ein Braunschweig-Spieler mal richtig ausgepackt und gesagt, das ist hier alles kacke. Wir müssten eigentlich alles abreißen. Die Methodiken, alles ist veraltet in diesem Verein. War das Sven Köler?
Ja.
Der, glaube ich, generell durchaus ein… Also nicht ohne Grund Kapitän, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, genau.
Klarer Worte.
Ja, ja, definitiv.
Und dann entschied man sich dafür, Heiner Backhaus zu holen, der erst 43 ist. Also schon… Und ja, offensichtlich ein neues Zweitliga-Gesicht. Der Mann hat sich hochgearbeitet. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Also der war Trainer bei Inter Leipzig, Reden, Sonnenhof, Groß Asbach, Koblenz, BFC Dynamo, Aachen und ist jetzt bei Braunschweig angekommen. Nun muss man sagen, dass Heiner Backhaus trotzdem jemand ist, der schon viel Geschichte mitbringt, weil er hat gefühlt bei jedem Verein bislang heiße Luft, äh heiße Luft, nee, verbrannte Erde, andere Feuermetapher, auch heiß. Auch heiß. Alles ist heiß. Heißt ja auch Backhaus mit Nachnamen.
Ja.
Es schließt sich in den Kreis. Das ist alles sehr... Er gibt alles Sinn. Aber welchen Eindruck hat er gemacht zum... Also, wie wurde er aufgenommen? Wie hat er sich zu Beginn präsentiert? Und wie hat sich das Bild vielleicht schon nach 8 Spielen gefestigt, gewandelt? Führe uns da gerne mal ein.
Ich glaube, bei vielen kam der total gut an am Anfang. Weil der ist so ein super Rhetoriker. Und ich glaube, gerade nach diesem schrecklichen Mai und die Relegationsspiele waren wirklich schlimm. Es ist wirklich schrecklich gewesen, in die Verlängerung gehen zu müssen gegen Saarbrücken zu Hause, nachdem die aus dem Nichts doch noch zwei Tore machen. Und du hängst da halb in der dritten Liga drin und du denkst, fuck, das war es dann halt auch wahrscheinlich. Weil keine Ahnung, wie wir das noch heilen sollen. Und du brauchst dann schon jemanden, der da irgendwie einen Fuß in diese Krisentür bekommt. Entweder ein weicher Typ, der das irgendwie so ein bisschen väterlich macht. Und Buckhaus ist halt eher der, ja, so, ne, wir machen das jetzt neu und es wird super. Und wir stehen jetzt zusammen und als Team und so weiter und so fort. Und dann gab es sehr natürlich zwei Lager in Braunschweig, nämlich diejenigen, die das alles so ein bisschen fischy fanden, den Abgang aus Aachen, weil der da ja große, treue Schwüre geleistet hat. Sogar auf seinen toten Vater gesagt hat, er verlässt den Verein nicht.
Und Ähnliches, vielleicht nicht auf den toten Vater, hat er halt auch schon beim BFC Dynamo abgezogen, um dann zu Aachen zu gehen.
Und ich finde, es ist so ein bisschen– ich verstehe, wenn Leute dieses Seifentheater auch ein bisschen mitspielen wollen, weil natürlich willst du gemocht werden und keine Ahnung. Ich wohne in Hannover, da sagen immer alle Trainer, oh, die Stadt ist so grün. Ja, okay. Und ich dachte aber, ja, okay, was ist ja irgendwie was anderes, als das, was er da offenbar irgendwie von sich gegeben hat an Zuneigungsbekundungen. Und ich fand es ein bisschen auch so die Reaktion bei Social Media. Klar, gibt es dann irgendwie Hass vom abgebenden Verein. Aber da waren auch wirklich sachliche Stimmen dabei, die gesagt haben, boah, irgendwie, das war echt nicht okay, was der hier gemacht hat. Und es gab halt im Braunschweig Leute, die gesagt haben, boah, irgendwie traue ich dem Typen nicht. Und andere, die gesagt haben, ja, das ist das Geschäft. Leg mal irgendwie hier deine Mentalität ab, deine Leichtgläubigkeit. Man muss das Spiel eben mitspielen. Wir profitieren doch auch davon, wenn wir irgendwo Last-Minute-Spieler ablösen können, blablabla. Und was ich ganz spannend finde, ist, dass ich den Eindruck habe, zumindest, wenn ich die Kommentare bei Instagram sehe und inzwischen auch bei YouTube. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie ihr das beobachtet. Ich finde, bei YouTube ist die Kommentarspalte schon noch mal ein bisschen tougher. Aber auf beiden Plattformen sagen die Leute, was ist denn jetzt deine Idee, bis auf Kampf und so? Weil irgendwie, also es funktioniert ja nicht. Und das ist ja okay, dass es nicht funktioniert. Wir müssen ja rausfinden, was funktioniert. Aber um rausfinden zu können, was funktioniert, müsste man halt irgendwie was verändern. Und wenn er was verändert, über personelle Maßnahmen hinweg, dann sehe ich das irgendwie nicht so richtig. Also ja, und das macht mich wirklich ratlos und auch so ein bisschen betroffen, weil da natürlich auch Benny Kessel dranhängt, also unser Sportdirektor, der immerhin ihm auch 100.000 Euro für den Trainer ausgegeben hat. Was ich viel finde für einen Drittliga-Trainer und eine Zweitliga-Erfahrung, weil der Kader besser ist. Also wir konnten jetzt auch mit Yadimchi und– jetzt muss ich den Namen einmal nachgucken– eine Leitgabe aus Leipzig, die leider noch nicht gespielt hat. Ne, tatsächlich auch im Sturm. Ach, der. Robert Ramsack. So ganz vielversprechend unseren schmerzhaftesten Abgang, nämlich Rayon Philippe, Richtung HSV kompensieren. Und ich traue dem Kader wirklich mehr zu, als das, was letzte Saison in Braunschweig stattgefunden hat. Und es ist bedauerlich, dass davon so wenig zu sehen ist. Hängt vielleicht auch mit der frühen und langen Verletzung von Lino Tempelmann zusammen. Das ist natürlich krass, was da passiert ist. Auch da zum Hintergrund die Chronologie ist, man konnte Ron-Thomas Hoffmann von Schalke wieder los eisen, der ja dorthin abgewandert war, kurzzeitig dann wieder zurückgegangen ist. Und von Ron-Thomas Hoffmann, der im Tor steht, ging halt wirklich maßgeblich der Transfer von Lino Tempelmann auch aus Schalke zur Braunschweigereintracht zurück. Das heißt, der hat da wirklich effektiv Fäden gezogen. Und es wäre schade, wenn diese Bemühungen ins Leere laufen.
Er hat jetzt ja gegen Paderborn gespielt, Lino Tempelmann. Es ging ja auch nochmal merklichen Ruck durch die Mannschaft. Es ist ja schon jemand, der spielerisch wie emotional dieser Mannschaft viel gibt. Das hat man ja auch in der Rückrunde gespürt. Da ging ja gefühlt alles über ihn und seine Distanztore. Generell der Dreierpark aus Schalke, Hoffmann, Tempelmann, Aydin, der hat gesessen. Ich finde generell die Transfer-Sommer, der ist nicht so schlecht. Ich bin großer Fan von Robin Häusler. Ich verstehe nicht, warum der beim KSC nicht funktioniert hat, weil ich den in Wiesbaden richtig gut fand. Aber ich finde den gut. Frenkert hast du schon angesprochen, ordentlicher Innenverteidiger. Du hast den Kader verjüngt. Klar, Rayan Philipp, das tut weh, aber ich finde, dass du mit Jadim Schi eigentlich eine gute Antwort gefunden hast, vom Profil her. Aber Thomas, um dich mal kurz in die Szene zurückzuholen, du hast ja nun am ersten Spieltag die wuchtige Braunschweige Eintracht erlebt. Was war denn das für ein Spiel und wie blickst du dann mit den weiteren Spielen dann auf die Herangehensweise von Heiner Backhaus? Gerade hört man dich nicht. Jetzt hört man dich.
So, jetzt müsste sie mich hören. Richtig. Ja, also ich weiß nicht, wie jeder das sieht, aber das erste Spiel, ich glaube, da kam Braunschweig zu drei Punkten, wie die Jungfrau zum Kind. Also das war ja ein Spiel auf ein Tor und dann schießen die da einmal aus Tor und unter gütiger Mithilfe unseres Abwehrspielers und unseres Torhüters geht der Ball dann rein. Ja, und ansonsten hat man, also ich finde, man hat da schon gesehen, spielerisch ist von Braunschweig, ich weiß nicht, ob es am Trainer liegt oder grundsätzlich, aber spielerisch von Braunschweig glaube ich nicht viel zu erwarten. Also ich fand das nicht gut gegen uns, auch wenn sie dann am Ende drei Punkte geholt haben, das ist entscheidend am Ende. Aber das war kein gutes Spiel von Braunschweig. Natürlich auch die Tatsache, die rote Karte, die dazu kam. Da wurde natürlich klar, dass man dann noch mehr sich auf die Defensive konzentriert. Das ist auch völlig in Ordnung. Aber ich fand das Spiel damals schon von Braunschweig nicht so stark. In Viert kann ich nichts zu sagen, das Spiel habe ich nicht gesehen. Aber was man jetzt bei Eintracht sieht, das wirkt alles noch nicht so gefestigt. Auch innerhalb greift einfach nicht, habe ich das Gefühl. Man hat den Eindruck, dass der Eintrachter das Spiel noch ein bisschen falsch geltet. Aber offensiv wirkt das auch ein bisschen zufällig. Man hat es gesehen, die Paterbornen haben mit relativ einfachen Mitteln geschafft, Braunschweig immer wieder vom Tor wegzuhalten und kaum etwas zugelassen. Obwohl man da gar nicht viel investieren musste, hatte ich den Eindruck auf Paterborner Seite. Buckhaus scheint so ein Trainer zu sein, der– Anna hat es auch gesagt– viel über Emotionen kommt. Ich glaube, wenn das irgendwann mal vorbei ist, dann wird es schwierig, wenn du keinen klaren Spielplan hast. Man ist es nicht mehr zu erkennen, dass man sagt, wir versuchen, defensiv grundsätzlich gut zu stehen und dann über einen klaren Umschaltfußball und über starke Standardsituationen zum Erfolg zu kommen. So ein bisschen sieht man in Braunschweig noch nicht so ein Konzept. Die Frage ist, wie lange geht das gut? Klar, man hat am Anfang jetzt sieben Punkte geholt in den ersten drei Spielen. Aber jetzt inzwischen sieht man ja schon, dass da eine Mannschaft an ihre Grenzen kommt. Und es ist wirklich interessant zu sehen, woran liegen die Grenzen? Liegt es am Trainer oder liegt es am Kader? Und das ist jetzt wirklich, glaube ich, auch eine Frage, die sich da stellen, die man sich langsam in Braunschweig stellen muss. Und ich finde die Aussage von Benjamin Kessel, glaube ich, heißt er. Ich hoffe, ich habe dir jetzt keinen Mist erzählt. Da muss man schon sagen, das ist schon vielsand, wenn dann ein Sportdirektor sich hinstellt oder ein Sportchef sich hinstellt und nach dem Spiel dann so eine Aussage trifft, finde ich schon krass. Und das scheint jedoch zu zeigen, dass man scheinbar jetzt mit der spielerischen Entwicklung in Braunschweig auf oberer Etage nicht ganz so zufrieden ist, um es mal ein bisschen vorsichtig auszudrücken.
Ich fand das Interview von Benjamin Kessel aber wirklich gut von außen, weil das war gerechtfertigt kritisch, das war angenehm ehrlich, das war also ohne unsachlich zu werden oder so. Aber ich finde, ohne es direkt sagen zu müssen, zählt er den Trainer eben doch an. Also er spricht klar davon, dass in der Länderspielpause der Reset-Knopf gefunden werden muss. Das heißt eben auch, man geht mit einer Bacchus in diese Länderspielpause, aber wenn es dann die ersten ein, zwei Spiele danach keine Verbesserung gibt, dann wird man auch nicht zögern. Und ich finde, das spricht aber auch für einen Leistungsgedanken, der erstmal ja gut ist, dass man das auch zugeben könnte. Ja, okay, wir haben aufs falsche Pferd gesetzt. Das sah in Aachen bei dem gut aus, wir wollten Ähnliches hier merken auf Zweitliganiveau, funktioniert das reine Anzünden von Spielern vielleicht nicht so gut. Das ist ja eine Erkenntnis. Und jetzt hat man halt auch wirklich das Krisen-Duell, doch ist schon so, dann gegen Düsseldorf. Das wird ja schon spannend. Und ich meine, Anna, wir können jetzt auch einen Riesenpunkt aufmachen, dieses herumgeeiere generell von Eintracht, was du ja auch schon öfter in diesem Podcast hier beschrieben hast. Ich habe mal nachgeguckt, ich konnte es kaum fassen. Man ist also seit 2018, es ist ein ständiges herumgeeiert zwischen Dritt und Zweiter Liga. Man hat fünf komplette Zweitligasaisons seitdem gespielt. Platzierungen in der zweiten Liga sind 17, 17, 15, 15, 16 und aktuell 15. Das ist ja irre. Ja, absolut. Vielleicht auch da, um das zurückzuholen, was Sven Köhler gesagt hat, dass eigentlich alles in diesem Verein general überholt werden müsste. Und verbunden mit einem Benjamin Kessler, der ja noch eigentlich, also klar, alter Braunschweiger, aber in dieser Funktion ja ein unverbrauchtes Gesicht ist, hast du denn das Gefühl, jetzt mal abseits von der aktuellen sportlichen Situation, dass man in Braunschweig verstanden hat, dass man jetzt auch mal wieder Schritte nach vorne gehen muss und Vision haben muss. Oder fühlt sich das doch insgesamt immer noch ja Bleyern und Altbacken an?
Ich glaube, die Bemühungen sind absolut da. Also zum Beispiel auch eben deshalb bei mir die große Hoffnung, die ich in Ron Tom Hoffmann gesetzt habe, dass er einfach jemand sein kann, der mannschaftsintern nach innen und außen dafür sorgt, dass wir so ein bisschen ablegen, ein Verein zu sein, der in der 2. Liga besteht, weil er so die alten Spieler aufträgt. So. Sondern junge Spieler holt und holen kann, die vielleicht sogar woanders hingegangen werden, aber die einfach Bock haben, irgendwie sich in dem Team für ein paar Jahre zu entwickeln oder so. Und das war halt einfach das Kriterium, dass die Eintracht erfolgreich gemacht hat in ihren erfolgreichen Jahren. Und das glaube ich auch im Moment der ausschlaggebende Punkt, warum leihen Bundesligisten Top-Talente nach Elbersberg aus, weil sie wissen, dass es da funktioniert. Warum leihen Freiburg-Spieler nach Kiel aus, weil sie wissen, dass es da funktioniert. Und ich glaube, du musst einfach dringend rauskommen aus diesem, aus dem Grappeltischbereich. Und ich hatte im Sommer eigentlich das Gefühl, dass das funktioniert. Und wie gesagt, ich bleibe auch dabei. Ich finde den Kader, vielleicht hast du halt nicht, du hast halt nicht diesen Philipp, du hast nicht diesen Stern, obwohl er unter diesem Dasein für mein Empfinden jetzt auch nicht immer top performt hat. Er ist ein junger Typ so und da irgendwie immer das Wohl und Wehe auf den eigenen Schultern zu spüren und tragen zu müssen, ist sicherlich irgendwie auch nicht cool. Ja, aber das ist halt so ein bisschen die Frage, dieses Steilgeruch-Thema, dass er Vereine immer wieder irgendwie beschäftigt. Wie viel braucht man da? Was ist die richtige Dose?
Da sind wir wieder bei den Pferden.
Ja, genau. Was ist die richtige Dose Steilgeruch? Weil Benny Kessey kommt, oder er hat in Braunschweig lang gespielt, ist dann wieder zurückgekommen, Rettungsaktionen, dies, das und so. Und jetzt ist er da sehr aktiv mit Marc Pfitznern, der ist Co-Trainer geblieben, über die Trainer hinweg. Und ich glaube, du musst halt schon aufpassen, dass du nicht in Richtung Klüngel kippst.
Jaja, voll. Auch das kennt man bei der Hertha aus Berlin sehr gut. Es ist ein schmaler Grad, definitiv.
Ja, und dann denke ich auch, ja, Klüngeln, warum so? Also könnt ihr euch mal irgendwie raffen und einordnen. Wir sind irgendwie ein ganz okayer, hoffentlich beständiger Zweitligist in einer sehr durchschnittlichen Stadt. Also kann man sich da irgendwie mal ein bisschen irgendwie reflektieren, dass man echt nicht die geilste Adresse ist und dass man das irgendwie kompensieren muss. Also, und das ist ja völlig okay. So ich liebe Braunschweig, ich liebe den Verein und alles super. Aber das ist einfach nicht the place to be in der ganzen Republik. Es ist eben so. So in Kiel hast du wenigstens das Meer. In Freiburg kannst du gut Fahrrad fahren, da scheint immer die Sonne.
Was ist denn die Attraktion in Braunschweig? Gibt es eine Braunschweig-Attraktion? Touristenattraktion? Weiß das gar nicht. Ich war noch nie in Braunschweig.
Ja, dann wird es aber Zeit auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, dass du darüber schon kommen kannst. Da hat Backhaus schon einen Punkt. Die Braunschweiger stehen hinter jedem Sportverein, der da performt. Die stehen hinter den Basketballlöwen. Die füllen auch beim Handball-Endspiel in der 3. Liga. Da ist die Halle voll. Wir gehen dahin, Tabellenkeller, gerade Relegationen durchgekämpft, Stadion 21.000 Leute. Und deswegen nervt es mich so– und jetzt schweife ich hier doch ein bisschen ab und es wird ein bisschen emotionaler –,Dass sich da dann jemand hinstellt und sagt, er würde sich so ein bisschen stören an der negativen Grundhaltung der Braunschweiger. Und ich denke so, willst du mich verarschen?
Warum seid ihr denn so gestresst, Anna?
Ja, hast du dir mal irgendwie angeguckt, was hier die letzten Jahre passiert ist?
Lächeln doch mal.
Du hast negativer Fächtung. Wir haben noch ein paar Tore geschossen seit dem Sommer. Ja, aber die Wunden sind echt tief. Und ich kenne einige, die jetzt drohen in so einer Fußballdepression, ohne psychische Krankheiten beschönigen zu wollen, aber die einfach wirklich abstumpfen. Die das nicht mehr fühlen. Die das auch nicht mehr schrecklich finden. Und da muss der Verein irgendwie wirklich dringend, dringend, dringend was tun. Deswegen kann ich schon nachvollziehen, warum man Buckhausen eine gute Besetzung fand, um diesen ganzen Brei wieder ein bisschen zu lösen. Aber dafür braucht er dann doch in dieser spröden Kämpferansprache ein bisschen mehr Feingefühl dafür, dass wir hier echt in der Scheiße stecken. Also, naja.
Ich finde, ehrlich gesagt, auf der Note sollten wir es beenden. Manchmal ist so eine Kampfansage zum Ende genau das Richtige. Und wir haben ja auch noch einen Verein. Und da hole ich dann auch Thomas wieder mehr rein. Ist ja auch unfair, jetzt einfach zu sagen, Dresden, weil es im Osten ist, kann es ja auch. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es doch ein bisschen näher als andere Vereine. Seien wir ehrlich. Wir reden jetzt über Dynamo Dresden. Die stehen nämlich immer noch hinter Eintracht Braunschweig. Das ist doch schon mal was. Und das, ja, ich glaube, 4 Punkte? Nee, ne, stimmt gar nicht. 1 Punkt. Dresden hat 6 Punkte. So wird ein Shoot raus. Dynamo Dresden, das wissen wir alle. So viel haben wir mitbekommen, ist zurück in der zweiten Liga. Das ist natürlich ein Gewinn für diese Liga, diesen wuchtigen Traditionsverein zurückgewonnen zu haben. Doch wie ist Dresden überhaupt gestartet? Nun ja, mindestens mal durchwachsen. Erst ein Sieg in 8 Spielen, seit 5 Spielen kein Sieg mehr. Das größte Problem, ich nehme es vorweg, ist wohl die Abwehr, würde ich behaupten. Man hat noch kein Spiel zu Null gespielt, man hat 16 Gegentore. Das war vorm Spieltag die schwächste Abwehr. Nee, das war zwischenzeitlich an diesem Spieltag die schwächste Abwehr. Ich weiß nicht, ob heute jemand so viel kassiert hat, dass sich das geändert hat. Ich gucke live nach. Ah, guck mal, ja siehst du. Ja stimmt, Magdeburg 19, ja. Und Fürth 18. Es ist die drittschlechteste Abwehr. Das hat sich ein bisschen verbessert, ist trotzdem Alarmsignal. Thomas, was für ein Eindruck macht Dynamo Dresden bislang auf dich? Wo liegen die großen Probleme? Wo muss man ansetzen?
Also für mich klassischer Aufsteiger. Also Dresden erinnert mich sehr an unsere erste Saison damals, als wir aufgestiegen sind unter Christian Tietz. Das ist für mich genau das Gleiche. Offensiv einen guten Plan, der auch in regelmäßigen Abständen funktioniert. Es ist ja schon so, Dresden ist schon in der Lage, sich Chancen rauszuspielen. Sie machen auch Tore, aber eben, was du sagst, defensiv diese Stabilität, die ist noch komplett verloren. Das ist, glaube ich, das große Problem, was Dresden hat. Ich glaube, die Spielidee, die dort herrscht, auch das Spielermaterial, was man hat, passt gut zu dieser Spielidee. Die Frage ist einfach, schafft das Dynamo Dresden, so in dieser Liga anzukommen, dass man eben am Ende diese Punkte holt. Ich würde sagen, ja. Ich finde, man ist in Dresden auf einem guten Weg. Wenn man es jetzt schafft, defensiv diese Stabilität reinzubekommen, glaube ich schon, dass das eine Mannschaft ist, die genug offensive Wucht entwickeln kann, eben Spiele auch mal 1 zu 0 oder 2 zu 1 zu gewinnen und dann eben auch drin zu bleiben. Das hat man jetzt auch gesehen gegen den KSC. Ich meine, gegen die musste erst mal drei Tore machen. Am Ende haben sie sogar ein bisschen Pech. Ich bin der Meinung, die können in der Schlussphase sogar noch 4 zu 3 gewinnen.
Seid gleichzeitig Glück, dass sie das Tor noch so kurz vor Schluss machen.
Keine Frage, aber sie haben danach sogar noch die Möglichkeit, das Spiel auch noch zu entscheiden für sich. Also von daher, ja, ich glaube schon, Dresden hat ein bisschen gebraucht. Also ich fand das erste Spiel gegen Fürth, auch wenn sie da zwei Tore geschossen haben und auch viel Ballbesitz hatten, fand ich schon, hat man gesehen, wo die Probleme einfach sind. Auch gegen uns, fand ich, hat man das gesehen. Schön, dass wir das Spiel wenigstens gewinnen konnten. Irgendwas ist schön. Ja, aber auch da hat man gesehen und da dachte ich mir so, oh, Dresden wird mal gucken. Aber die haben sich, finde ich, seitdem zumindest offensiv schon auch gesteigert, haben auch, finde ich, verdient in Bielefeld gewonnen. Wenn sie am Ende auch ein bisschen glücklich waren, natürlich mit diesem Tor des Monats, was sie da machen, auch, ja. Aber das haben sie eben in den ersten Spielen nicht gehabt und haben da auch verdient gewonnen. Und ich glaube schon, Dresden ist, finde ich, aus meiner Sicht, eigentlich grundsätzlich auf einem guten Weg, auch wenn die Ergebnis jetzt vielleicht noch nicht ganz so dafür sprechen.
Ja, ich war ja recht skeptisch, aber schon sorgenvoll in der Saisonprognose, weil ich da schon mehr oder weniger diese Überschrift hatte, nur Wucht wird nicht reichen. Und das Wort hast du jetzt auch schon genutzt, Thomas. Damit beschreibt man Dresden bislang sehr gut. Ich finde, das ist so ein Phasenteam. In manchen Minuten sehen die herausragend gut aus. Dann entwickeln die eine krasse Wucht im 4-2-2-2 oder 4-3-3, was sie jetzt spielen unter Trainer Thomas Stamm. Das stellt den Gegnern vor Probleme. Daferner, Lemmer, Fröding, das kann richtig Spaß machen. Das hat richtig Dampf. Auch, weil die auf Ausseher sehr hoch schieben. Also Risch und so. Oder auf der anderen Seite, wie heißt der Wind, den sie da geholt haben, Mosgallen. Ist ja auch egal. Das kann richtig Wucht entwickeln. Mir fehlt aber echt die Balance im Spiel. Das zeigt allein, wie schnell Dynamo sich nach eigenen Treffern direkt das Gegentor fängt. Das habe ich jetzt nicht noch mal komplett nachvollzogen, aber es war gefühlt immer so im Spiel, dass wenn sie das Tor machen, relativ schnell dann auch das Gegentor fällt, weil Euphorie weiter nach vorne. Wie machen es jetzt? Ich finde bislang recht, sich die Transferphase– ist ja nicht immer möglich, um Gottes Willen– aber man hat eigentlich keine Zweitliga-Erfahrung dazugewonnen und man hatte sie auch nicht im Kader. Es ist kein Zweitliga-Erfahrung im Kader, im Gegenteil. Dadurch fehlt Dresden so eine Coolness, so eine Ruhe, um auch mal weniger Fehler zu machen. Sie machen ja sehr viele einfache Fehler. Das ist jetzt auch gegen den KSC passiert. Also, eigener Ballverlust kurz vor dem 16er, Gegentor. Das zieht sich echt durch. Was auch Sorgen machen muss, sind die Heimspiele. Ich hätte gedacht, das ist das Faust-Hand von Dynamo Dresden diese Saison. Pustekuchen. Bislang zwei Punkte aus vier Heimspielen. Auch da vielleicht eine Druck-Thematik. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Das ist natürlich immer schnell dahergesagt. Ich habe jetzt die Spielverläufe nicht mal komplett nachvollzogen. Aber ich hätte eher gedacht, dass Dresden die Punkte zu Hause holt. Anna, was ist denn so dein Bild bislang von der SGB?
Ja, also ich finde sie wirklich sehr spielstark tatsächlich. Also ich habe sie gegen Hannover etwas konzentrierter gesehen und jetzt natürlich auch gestern in dem Spiel gegen den KSC. Das ist so ein bisschen das Komplementärstück eigentlich zu unseren Problemen, weil die halt mit dem Ball richtig super unterwegs sind und ohne Ball echt dürftig unterwegs sind. Also für Fußballliebhaber Eintracht Braunschweig gegen Dynamo Dresden, das wird ein Hit. Und mit Blick auf den Kader, finde ich, spiegelt sich das so ganz gut wieder. Du hattest eben gerade die Zweitliga-Erfahrung angesprochen, die ich in der Innenverteidigung, glaube ich, auch nicht so sehr sehe. Aber in der Offensive schon. Also mit Christoph Daferne, der ja auch regelmäßig trifft, der vom Club kam. Vincent Vermeil von Fortuna Düsseldorf. Und dann natürlich der ähnliche Wut wie Martin Warnizek, Stefan Kutschke. Also als der gestern im Fernsehen aufgetaucht ist, habe ich kurz auf die Uhr geguckt und dachte, ja krass, der spielt noch, weil der hat natürlich auch Zweitliga-Erfahrung von vorigen Ausflügen. Und das ist halt wirklich phänomenal, finde ich, dass das einfach halt funktioniert, wenn du da so einen energiegeladenen, ein Schlachtross, es ist ein Pferd.
Das Pferd.
Das habe ich getan.
Ist das gut. Der 36-jährige bürtige Dresdner. Ich habe mal geguckt, 130 Zweitligaspieler hat er immerhin auf dem Tacho.
Wahnsinn.
Hättest du, aber könntest du mir sagen, wo er die geholt hat? Ich muss noch mal gucken. Nürnberg, Dresden und Ingolstadt.
Guck mal an. Krass. Na gut, er ist 36. Ja, genau. Das funktioniert halt einfach. Und ich finde das so krass, weil ja klar, auch gerade eine Mannschaft, in der du Zweitliga-Erfahrungen noch so ein bisschen aufbauen musst, sowas einfach zur Orientierung so sehr hilft, wie so ein, so läuft das hier. Und wenn ich mal irgendwie nicht reicher weiß.
Er spielt ja auch gar nicht mehr so viel, aber er ist da.
Aber er ist da, genau. Und wenn er spielt, dann merkt man ihn halt auch. Und wenn nicht in den Aktionen, dann in der Interaktion mit dem Gegner, physischer Art oder...
Schiedsrichter.
Genau. Ja. Und das finde ich super wichtig. Und einfach smart, den zu halten. Das finde ich halt so Aspekte in der Kaderplanung, die super, super essenziell sind. Also Leuchttürme.
Das ist genau so ein Spielertyp, wie er bei uns komplett fehlt.
Ja. Total.
Genau so ein Typ, der uns halt fehlt.
Drecksau. Um anderes Tier mal zu nennen. Guck mal, die haben im Kader Alexander Rossipal.
Ja, ein Pferd.
Ja, eben. Da kann eigentlich gar nichts mehr schiefgehen an der Stelle. Das tut mir leid. Da kann mein Gehirn dann irgendwann nicht mehr loslassen von der Geschichte.
Den Witz reiten wir jetzt weiter.
So, sehr, sehr gut. Guck mal. Abschließende Worte zu Dynamo Dresden. Ich, um Gottes willen, die brauchst du nicht abschreiben. Die haben eine Wucht. Da gibt es definitiv die Kreativität, wie die Spiele gewinnen. Das ist vielleicht so, wie mir Fantasie bei Braunschweig fehlt, habe ich sie definitiv bei Dresden, wie die Spiele gewinnen wollen, um Gottes willen. Aber sie haben halt nicht mehr im Vergleich so hohe individuelle Klasse wie in der 3. Liga, sodass sie einfach dieses wir schießen halten Tor mehr als der Gegner spielweise einfach so durchziehen können. Und da erwarte ich mir auch von Thomas Stamm, den Trainer, den ich für einen fähigen Trainer halte und nicht ohne Grund hat der Dresden hochgeführt. Da wird es irgendwann eine weitere Dimension brauchen im Spiel. Und nicht nur Wucht, nicht nur Flanken. Das ist ja die flankenintensivste Mannschaft der 2. Liga. Die Cup wollen da alles reinschädeln. Und das kann auch in der 2. Liga wunderbar funktionieren. Da gibt es genug Beispiele. Schalke schafft es gerade auch ohne eine wirkliche Spielanlage, Tabellen zweiter zu sein, völlig irre. Und die sehen mitbei definitiv schlechter aus als Dresden. Aber sie sind defensiv gut. Und Dresden muss dahingehend echt was machen. Vielleicht fällt auch da im Winter ja der ein oder andere Spieler runter, dass sie sich da vielleicht nochmal was zusammenleihen können. Bis dahin gilt es, den Anschluss zu halten. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das Programm jetzt aussieht. Ich rufe es de facto jetzt auf. Ja, ich meine, Münster-Paderborn-Hertha ist jetzt auch nicht leicht. Immerhin zwei Auswärtsspiele dabei. Wie gesagt, zu Hause sieht es ja aktuell nicht so gut aus. Aber es sind jetzt auch nicht die Spiele, wo man sagt, jo, da, die Kehrtwende, gar kein Problem. Wobei sie, Hertha, also Berlin, werden sie einnehmen. Ich erinnere mich an ein Pokalspiel zwischen Dresden und Hertha. Das war die beeindruckendste Auswärtskulisse, die ich je im Olympiastadion gesehen habe. Das war absurd. Und ich glaube, das werden sie sich jetzt nicht nehmen lassen nach der 2. Rückkehr. Aber so viel dazu. Ich denke, Dynamo haben wir somit auch besprochen. Es gibt bestimmt auch noch tausend andere Themen. Ist nun mal ein großer Trajitionsverein. Thomas, du hast kurz aufgeatmet. Wolltest du noch was einschieben?
Na, ich glaube tatsächlich, in Dresden, das ist so ein bisschen auch die Wette, die du jetzt eingehst, die du jetzt aufsteigend auch eingehen musst. Hast du ein bisschen so junge Spieler, dann hast du den ein oder anderen erfahren, damit da ferner, oder auch Kutschka. Und hoffst einfach, dass die jungen Spieler jetzt im Laufe der Saison so diesen Schritt machen. Und dann im Winter eben vielleicht noch ein, zwei Spieler dazuholen. Und ich glaube, dann kann das funktionieren. Also, weil ich glaube, das Wichtigste, was du brauchst, und ich finde, das hat Dresden, ist halt eine klare Idee, wie man Spiele beschreiten will. Die haben sie. Und wenn sie das noch schaffen, dass eben der eine oder andere Spieler den nächsten Entwicklungsschritt macht, oder vielleicht dazu noch im Winter die eine oder andere gute Ergänzung holen, dann kann das funktionieren. Ich glaube, von denen, die da unten jetzt gerade stehen und alle Probleme haben, traue ich Dresden das noch am ehesten zu, in der Konstellation, in der man ist, mit Trainern, mit Spielern, da eben auch am ehesten noch diesen Sprung nach oben zu schaffen. Eben auch, weil man da auch, wie du schon sagst, diese Wucht, die diese Stadion auch entwickeln kann, ich glaube schon, dass das ein Faktor sein kann. Und ich glaube, Dresden wird am Ende auch knapp, aber ich denke, die werden drin bleiben.
Sehr schön. Dann nehme ich die Moderationszügel in die Hand. Und führe aus dieser Sendung heraus, Anna, Thomas, das hat ganz, ganz großen Spaß gemacht. Vielen lieben Dank für eure Zeit, für eure Expertise. Das war nicht immer aufbauend, aber immer interessant. Und ansonsten, bevor ich euch hier aus der Sendung schicke, möchte ich natürlich noch erwähnen, es wird wieder Sendung geben. Oh, ich habe das falsche Audio abgespielt. Sehr gut. Passiert. Wir versuchen es nochmal. So, jetzt wird ein Schuh draus. Die Spenden ermöglichen ja auch, die ihr euch hier immer aus den Rippen leiert, dass es picke packe volle Rasenfunk-Wochen gibt. Am Sonntagabend gibt es die Bundesliga-Männer-Spieltag 6, Montagabend Bundesliga-Frauen-Spieltag 5. Bei den Männern gibt es dann die Länderspielpause. Dazu wird es auch beim Nationalteams-Feed wieder eine Sendung geben. rasenfunk.de ist gleich schon unterstützen. Schaut vorbei. Anna, Thomas, vielen lieben Dank und wir sind raus.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.